We've all accepted that social media has
completely changed the way we interact.
Right?
Hey there.
Come here alone often?
Excuse me, can't you see I'm in
the middle of a conversation?
[Ugh, so rude]
[Annoyed emoji]
[ANYWAY]
The other day, I randomly thought of this
friend who I hadn't seen in a long time.
So I went to her Facebook page,
to see what she's been up to,
when I saw..
(typing)
(gasp) She unfriended me..
(sad music)
BUT,
I reacted pretty well.
Hello?
Kate unfriended me!
What did I ever do to her? I don't deserve this!
Are you sure? Maybe it was an accident.
Oh, it was NOT an accident.
I refreshed, then I added her as a friend,
and she didn't accept my request!
Oh..I'm so sorry babe..
(sobbing)
She will pay for this.
I felt so stupid by how offended I was.
Cause it's like, what does it matter
that she unfriended me online, right?
Wrong.
This was someone I considered my friend.
It felt like a deliberate slight.
Even though I know it probably went like..
Hmm.
In my mind, I saw it as..
You thought we were friends.
You're dead to me.
(evil laughter)
And I kept wishing that we would BUMP
into each other in real life, you know?
As if that was gonna be my revenge.
And not just awkward as hell.
Oh!
Hannah, hey.
Hey, how are you?
You unfriended me.
We're not friends anymore, are we?
Well, I just--
No, it's fine. It's cool.
It's real cool.
(dramatic tone)
When you're unfriended,
Yes. Ooh, it hurts.
You go through the 5 stages of grief.
No no, she didn't--it was a mistake.
How dare SHE..unfriend ME?!
Please God, just friend me again,
everything will be okay..
I can't believe she unfriended me..
That's fine.
But it's okay.
Unfriending and unfollowing is now as much a
part of life as just breaking up or drifting apart.
And when I think of all the times I've
unfriended someone, it was never personal.
You know, it's cause I updated too much, or their
updates weren't relevant to my life anymore.
So it's all good.
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay HERE.
You're not going anywhere, I
have something to show you.
I wanna say thank you to Best Fiends
for sponsoring today's video.
Best Fiends is a free puzzle adventure battle game,
where you collect and upgrade characters to defeat slugs!
I'm currently on level 20, try to beat me
and tweet your scores at me.
Although fair warning, this
game is super highly addictive.
There will be a free gift on July 10th,
so be sure to play on that day to collect your gift.
There's also a new quest for
fan favorite character Gene,
who opens at level 100.
And if you beat it, you can win gold and diamonds.
New levels are out now.
Download the game for free from the link below.
I'm Annameda Akana,
Stay awesome Gotham.